previously on TV sins I'm gonna get 24th
century on his ass you hear me talking
hillbilly boy Birdemic shock and anarchy
roll jackets
I mean commercials Jack Herschel's
smoking while riding may be considered
badass among certain circles but I've
had ash fly in my eye before and now
it's the worst great so just go ahead
and assume the show will also be a lot
of pointless death that will eventually
lead to a spin-off show that is
basically the same as this one almost
all the brands in the store have been
covered by stickers or signs or blurred
out or turned around they even tape over
a book about Goldilocks I'm okay with
nobody wondering while the chips are
turned around but I'm not okay with two
people who never asked why a book about
wheels going round and round contains
zero wheels and a thirsty ringlet blonde
with no privacy boundaries also why go
through all the trouble to cover the
Goldilocks book with a fake cover leave
a real book on the top shelf that could
have worked perfectly for the scene also
also this tiny store has way too many
items on sale I think I'd rather pay
full price for everything and avoid the
discount bombardment now that's what I
call puts on sunglasses Oh firearm five
big says it was arson fire dick some
days you're the Beemer some days you're
the goddamn deer okay maybe but in this
case both the Beemer and the deer are in
really bad shape
can I choose neither or maybe today I
can be the left rear taillight just be
fun and comfy on my casing and
completely oblivious to the trauma at
the other end of the car just pretend
it's carve your own steak night at
sizzler maybe wrap some chain around the
hind legs and yank it out over the hood
before just remembering the bloody
corpse inside the vehicle that I assume
is meant to be salvaged gritty show has
to grit I guess there's a chainsaw
running as this guy wretches over the
side of the car door so where is the
chainsaw in his hands if so he's hacking
the out of the interior of this car and
you thought the Bluebell liquor jump was
an [ __ ] seriously folks a little
respect for the cream that has been iced
if the guns arson and gruesome deaths
weren't enough to clue me in to this
being a bummer of a show this very
pregnant addict was the bullet between
my eyes that's some top-notch nostalgic
box wiping acting right there folks
there's no sign of debris or dust so you
can already clearly read what
says but can you read the emotion they
only a hint at a particular backstory
quickly with the least amount of effort
stop by expositions are Australia stack
of photos solvent for the most amount of
information and the least amount of time
where did you get that name hashtag file
this moment under questions with obvious
answers that no one in their right mind
would ask because you know the guy's
gonna drop trou and show you you know
first safekeeping having dog no words
doing out of the dog again dog began out
of Chino two weeks ago she grossly
underestimate smiter tain a ton of code
names for people places drugs and guns
it's like Game of Thrones traded tips
and Dragons for leather and exhaust
fumes and I refuse to keep it all
straight with sticky notes string
thumbtacks and my single remaining Anna
mentioned Sam crow I know how she feels
the show is so depressingly dreary I've
been on the verge of tears for twenty
minutes I mean their anger tears sure
tears nonetheless fractured cheek broken
nose yeah he's lucky to be breathing the
show is doing some really groundbreaking
work in the tired antihero genre by
completely eliminating the hero part of
the equation well done look I don't
expect perfection but I do expect that
third punch not to look like you threw
it a foot and a half above his head also
I do expect perfection you want to do
the right thing by your family of course
uncle C you son holy I haven't seen two
guys face-to-face with voices this
gravely since Bradley Cooper and Sam
Elliott tussled on the stars born fun
fact the working title of the show was
bro hugs and tattoos with the broom
broom boys Jack's just got the smacked
out of him so there should be a growing
spotty red handprint right about here
not so much here or here but right here
tell us do not die easy no I just die
bloody that's the Irish in us that's our
racist flushing plastic if I've said it
once I've said it a million times guns
and buns is just another way of asking
for a second [ __ ] actually I only
said that once when you can't ride
anymore no vote my son in as president I
just want to make sure he's following in
the right father's footsteps or a show
about tough ass bikers and badass
ruffians this shirt does have a lot of
soap a stopper to it huh ad Skinner
isn't yelling a fox mulder in this scene
yes there's some things you can't change
I leave it there so I remember all that
behind me good for you Tara I fully
believe that your hard work to become a
surgeon and do good in society will
drive your decision to leave the town of
charming a better place some shows would
have killed you off eventually in a bet
crazy plot point being stabbed with a
barbecue fork while drowning
glad that won't ever happen on the show
that Jacqueline Alvarez is dummy
corporations in San Leandro along you
PAC way line here the lack of red
sharpie circling a location on this map
and the multitude of finger placement
has me sort of confused but sure let's
go do plot stuff wherever you just said
yeah I'm packing explosives for illegal
activity with not only the side door to
the garage ajar but also the main garage
door completely open in broad daylight
at a time when both you and the kids are
home even though I've been clear I don't
want you to know about it you the look
of betrayal in her eyes is so
heartbreaking that I'm reminded of the
many times I've brought home pizza but
forgotten my wife's breadsticks I didn't
know what to say still don't brave
admission from the writers room somehow
makes it into the final script we're
praying for battle complete with the
examination of one's self in the mirror
cliche Hellboy's angels the next few
minutes we will cut between Asian Elvis
the big gun run break-in and premature
infant surgery I think the show thinks
this is creative storytelling to me it
feels like someone is sitting on the
remote Wow got a command Asian Elvis for
remaining in character even when he's
getting his ass beaten Daniel day-lewis
couldn't be more method than this guy
what the hell is the problem nothing
didn't the Mayans just blow up a bunch
of propane tanks when they stole the
guns in the first place
like I guess the Sons of Anarchy are
more technically proficient what a wire
the place with explosives but the mind
method sure seemed pretty effective
Mayans yeah roll backdoor pilots long
gone by now
oh those Mayans were pulling in within
10 seconds of when Charlie started
working on that bomb even if he had
finished it up right away you'd be in
the same spot when adrenaline runs high
and nobody cares about ricochets doctors
without boundaries oh it's one happy
family it's like David Fincher decided
to direct this is us so precious
oh that's going to check my Lily what
the hell is that long ride from charming
the Oakland how come easy ride and
meeting me face to face so crank to my
pregnant ex-wife apologize to her don't
you say that I'm gonna put my so far up
your cloaca they think in flying when
they so crank to my pregnant ex
journey ahead of this agents going can
we talk what is it
you don't need meds you just listening
to the wrong voice feministas unite